milestone that seemed nearly unthinkable
just a year ago no one projected it
candles at washington national cathedral
burned
as the u.s marked 500 000 deaths from
the coronavirus
last night president biden led a vigil
at the white house including a moment of
silence to mourn those who are no longer
here
it was the first such event at the white
house flags will be flown
at half staff until sunset on friday
since the beginning of this pandemic our
lives to remember series has been
serving as a reminder of what this
pandemic has taken from families
and communities nationwide this morning
we're sharing the stories of
five of the remarkable people we've lost
[Music]
sonny fox was a beloved television host
would you like to have your own
television show that's what i want to
do that you want your own television
show he hosted wonderama
every sunday morning on new york's wnew
from 1959 to 67.
the four-hour kids show had no budget
fox would say so he made tv magic with
his guests
and with the kids themselves which one
fox's easy-going charm captivated a
generation of new york city children
he went on to be a game show host and
later
a producer and network executive a
pioneering broadcaster
fox was not a comic like most kids show
hosts
for them the kids were the audience he
said for me
the kids were the show sonny fox
was 95.
iris meda worked as a registered nurse
for 35 years
born in south carolina maida grew up
poor
and practically raised her five siblings
she dropped out of high school but later
inspired by her husband
earned her ged and pursued a nursing
degree
she became the first person in her
family to graduate from college
with honors
iris loved dancing sewing true crime
shows and her grandkids
she stopped working early last year but
bravely came
out of retirement during the pandemic to
teach
nursing students at a local college
it created a fire in her said her
daughter celine made a schlemel
she fearlessly went to the front lines
to do her part
iris maida was 70.
james gleeka hernandez was a mental
health advocate
and a musical director at california's
woodland opera house
for more than two decades
his life's purpose was about building
people up said his friend amy schuman
he had so much pride in his family and
his students
i love to be surprised and the kids
always surprised me that's my favorite
part of the show in december
during his battle with covet james
posted several updates
from the hospital your love and support
make
all the difference in the world james
died a few weeks later
with his husband david by his side
james gleeka hernandez was 61.
donnie kirksey was a staple in the
chicago basketball scene
for 40 years he coached at every level
of the game
and was a mentor and a father figure to
hundreds of athletes
including former nba player and michigan
basketball coach
juwan howard we lost the loved one
but a guy that had a huge imprint on my
life
helped me to be the man i am today
doni's family remembered him as the king
of practical jokes
but also a man of humility and integrity
his wife dion said i was living every
woman's dreams
he was the love of my life donnie
kirksey
was 57.
stephanie smith was an alumni
coordinator at her alma mater
south plains college when you set your
roots
in good old level and texas you know
you have a solid foundation she had a
photography business
on the side and volunteered for
operation
baby watch caring for hospitalized
foster children her father sonny said
she poured her heart and soul into her
work
and her laugh was the loudest one in the
house
because of the pandemic stephanie and
her fiance
jamie bassett were planning a small
november wedding
she posted all that matters is that i
get to marry my best friend
no matter how it looks or how it happens
but the week of their wedding stephanie
tested positive for the coronavirus
she died five days after they were
supposed to exchange
their vows jamie said the thing i loved
about her
is any feeling a person feels she would
feel
10 times harder she had a big heart
stephanie smith was 29.
just five of 500 000 stories
now i should note south plains college
has established a scholarship in
stephanie's name
she spent a lot of time raising money
for south plains college for
scholarships so her parents feel she's
continuing her work
on one other note i grew up watching
sunny fox
and wonderama yeah and dave morris who
puts on our microphones every day
was actually in the studio audience of
that show as a kid oh my gosh
big show sorry for interrupting it's
taken so much from so many families and
it's amazing how connected you can feel
to people you've never met
yeah it's the way that his team your
team picks out the the bites that
are chosen the facial expressions you
really do bring them to life and these
people are all dearly loved the families
all give us
all of these photographs and videos you
can tell they they appreciate
that their their folks are being honored
with just a few sentences 30 seconds or
a minute of remembrance their whole
lives come back to you
if you were to do that with all 500 000
people who died it would take a year
yeah to watch the whole thing yeah i'm
so sorry you never run out of material
that's that's the unfortunate part these
stories will end
someday